So guys, now the update on the new asylum law 2,024.
That new asylum law consigned deportation.
So finally the AMPO
conclude on the new deportation law.
And I will explain now what is fixed.
They want faster and easier deportations.
That is what they want.
And, um, I will mention now the points.
So people that commit crimes
should be now deported more easy than before.
So any crimes, avoid them.
Before people will get document,
they can commit crime
and nothing big will happen to them
apart from the punishment.
But now they say
if you commit even small,
small crimes
multiplied once in one year,
they can depart you then.
Before, if you supposed to be deported,
they was allowed to hold you
for 10 days in the deportation prison.
But now they increase the time to 28 days.
It is only families
that will not come in the partition prison.
Like, if you are a family
and you're supposed to be departed,
they will pick you
very short before the deportation date.
So they can bring you direct to the airport.
Another thing is,
if you had a lawyer in the asylum case,
you will not
not get the chance to get a lawyer
if you're in deportation prison.
But if no lawyer was involved in your asylum case,
then you have the chance to get
inside the deportation prison
a lawyer then.
Another point is
that the police now is allowed
to search in different Rooms in your Adderall house
for any points of your identification
like documents,
letters, papers,
phones and all that.
Before they was only allowed to search your own room,
but now they're allowed to search rooms
in the whole house.
Then they are also permitted to pick you in the night
before the deportation.
Anytime in the night.
Normally they supposed to come early morning,
like from 6:00
they can come and pick you.
But now they are permitted
to also come and pick you in the night.
Another thing is
deportations now will not be announced anymore.
Like they must not inform you
that you have to be deported.
The only people that have to be informed
that they're going to be deported
are families with children under 12 years.
They are also
allowed to put you in deportation prison
if you refuse to clear your identification
like your identity.
So they can hold you and force you to go.
For your documents
like passport to the embassy
and all that
are for identification.
So if you refuse,
they can pick you
and hold you
and force you to go.
That is what I see in the news
and that is the new update.